if you're a fan of sci-fi script honor
that is easy to understand why you might
be confused by its cancellation but it
seems like there was some good reasons
for sci-fi to pull the plug
here's why Krypton was blown up earlier
than expected if you judge it purely by
critical reception
Krypton's cancellation is confusing
critics almost unanimously praised the
series second season over its first
IGN's David Griffith called it bigger
and bolder and Derrick Joseph when we
got discovered wrote that a series was
quotes finally finding his potential but
the improvements didn't matter if no one
was watching it it's not that nobody
watched Krypton second season but the
numbers dropped significantly
according to cinema blend Krypton series
premiere was sci fi highest-rated debut
in four years but the numbers dropped
from there the average viewership for a
season 1 episode was close to 700 and
90,000 TV series finale reports a
Krypton second season finale attracted
only 350,000 viewers less than half of
the audience of most season 1 episodes
critics of Krypton's first season wrote
that the series with a slug to bother
following and that it was characterized
by both complicated plotting and boring
character arcs so while those same
critics may have been impressed with
Krypton's growth in the second season a
disappointing first season may have kept
viewers away the promise of more
doomsday and the appearance of the
violently vulgar Lobo may not have been
enough to win back fans who stopped
watching during the first season of the
show
Krypton takes place long before the
birth of kal-el known on earth as
Superman kal-el
my future grandson this is the story of
the house of El the protagonist cycle is
cows grandfather and when the series
opens has CERN jor-el Superman's father
hasn't been born yet
it's a Superman show with no Superman
and no Kryptonian even has superpowers
we could argue that Gotham was similarly
a Batman show without Batman but at
least Bruce Wayne is there as early as
the first season it was clear viewers
are watching his evolution into the dark
nights on Krypton Superman hasn't even
been conceived as of its final episode
Superman's father is an infant Gotham
took advantage of one of the Batman
franchises Chief strengths his deep
rogues gallery Superman on the other
hand doesn't enjoy a wealth of popular
villains the most famous is Lex Luthor
and Krypton setting and time period
makers involvement all but impossible by
the end of Krypton's second season we've
met General Zod Brainiac and doomsday
and that's pretty much it as far as
popular non-human Superman villains are
concerned mr. mix yes pit Lake might
have been a possibility and the newly
introduced fell and broke all sir he was
revealed to be responsible for Krypton's
destruction in the comics could have
shown up perhaps the show could have
brought in Darkseid who sent it out in
the season 2 finale but after that the
Wells pretty dry for space-based
Superman bodies Krypton's premise relies
heavily on time travel and it gets a
little confusing Adam Strange travels
back from the present to make sure
things unfold as they should I come from
a planet called Earth a time centuries
from now and I've come here to warn you
someone from the future has come to
destroy Krypton okay right he brings
Superman's cape with him but it
disintegrates by the end of the first
season the cape has reappeared but bears
the sigil of Zod there's also the odd
relationship between seg light Asad and
drew Zod who becomes General Zod second
leads2results parents and they never
seem to have a difficult time adjusting
for this new information they
immediately start speaking to drew as if
they raised them even though they just
met him and there's a little drawing
that Collin's Salman who plays drew Saad
is three decades older than the actors
playing his parents once drew Zod
assumes leadership of the planet in
season two no one has a problem
accepting he's a time traveler in the
first season acknowledging there might
be intelligent alien life in the
universe
said heresy yet in season two everyone
is fine with their leader having parents
young enough he could be their dad
Krypton is in the first comic book
series to get act by sci-fi in June 2019
the network announced that neither happy
nor deadly class both based on creator
own comics would be renewed
Krypton's semis took with it the
upcoming Lobo spin-off to sci-fi could
be getting skittish about a comic book
face series and it could have something
to do with the competition Marvel has a
wide slate of Disney Plus MCU series
coming agents of shield still has one
more season planned cloak and dagger and
Runaways of an upcoming crossover and
Hulu's Ghost Rider is on its way
Amazon Prime's the boys made a big
splash as did Netflix's umbrella Academy
and even though Swamp Thing barely got a
chance to prove itself the DC Universe
streaming service had successes were the
first seasons of titans and Doom Patrol
and they're still the upcoming star girl
then there's a CW's our reverse which is
still going strong arrow is about to
come to a close but they're still the
flash legends of tomorrow Supergirl
Black Lightning and the series premiere
of Batwoman most of those series will be
involved in a huge crisis on Infinite
Earths crossover it could be that the
powers that be a sci-fi are looking at
the field of superhero and comic book
shows and thinking there's just too much
competition out there it's not superhero
time unless a creative team planned the
series to feature an alternative
narrative to the story we all know
Krypton would have ended with the
destruction of the planet and the deaths
of most of the characters even by the
end of season 2 the show seemed to be
ditching the planets hoping to save
jor-el Nyssa uses Adam Zetas beam to go
to the planet run Brainiac and jor-el
are on their way to earth second Lobo
reforms a complicated alliance of their
own so if Krypton had made it to season
3 it doesn't seem like much of the show
would have taken place on the title
planet at least for a while the show
seemed to be expanding beyond the
boundaries of Superman's home planets
becoming more of a showcase for DC's
cosmic Methos Krypton's very premise
painted the series in a corner you can
only explain how non Kryptonian
characters keep shoving up on the planet
in so many ways and if you go too far
outside the original setting how do you
build a story back to focus on the final
Cataclysm at least has something
Krypton's writers weren't tough to
figure out now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
superhero TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]